all right guys you know sometimes
as a parent you buy something for your
kid but in reality
it's for you this is one of those times
so we've officially made this taika's
room because we felt like the other room
the one that you guys saw over here
which has already turned into instant
storage
was too small
so yes it's instantly storage and we
felt like it was too removed from the
family like this is the hallway right
where everything happens
and um
we feel like when you come in from where
everything happens you got to come all
the way down this hallway
to finally get to taika and we feel like
he's too removed from the action so we
want him to be in the action so
originally this room which was saved for
another guests were like dude I think
the ceiling's even taller here
see you see that how there's no extra
window on top of that window
but over here you have that and that so
I think that might be like a 10 foot
ceiling I think it's like a 12 foot
ceiling it's really tall
so because we have such a sick room to
start with
me and Mom were brainstorming okay so
obviously he's not gonna have his
grown-up ass weird blue velvet bed right
we're like What would be a sick-ass bed
for taika that he would have a blast on
and we started looking
and we found this bunk bed so I grew up
with a bunk bed even though I didn't
need one I don't have any brothers and
sisters but it's freaking CUNY as hell
and we found a sick ass bunk bed
uh that also has a slide on it so it's
like a built-in playground and now when
his homies or if his cousins come over
they have a place to stay and that's why
I'm saying
I think I'm more excited than he is
because it's like when I was a kid and
if you were to ask me if my dream come
true I've always wanted a tree house and
this is as close you're gonna get to
having a tree house in your room
so see you later bunk bed or blue bed
so what do we do
so now is the time where I uh we make a
second baby and I'm saying this because
the type of stuff that I'm down to do
the turn monitor on it's pretty nuts
it's not pretty handy around these parts
of town and anytime I'm handy like this
and I start messing with the nuts and
bolts
nuts and bolts and model Bears nuts and
bolts get crazy it gets freaking freaky
I'm sick
wow so strong
yeah yeah just like that so for all of
you guys who aren't as manly as me the
way this socket wrench works and why
it's so awesome is once you lock it into
place it'll go on one side but then it
cranks this side which is why it's so
much easier than pliers for all you
non-menly men like me
so take that apart wow so strong wow
I just know how it works is I put this
bed together all by myself
no you didn't I totally did don't even
say that
don't even say that
all right so we completely disassembled
the bed
as you can see
so now we cleared out some space
in this taika storage room
to put the bed right here
I don't know if that's gonna fit
um and to be honest what we should have
done is actually organize a storage room
so we have more room for storage
but both me and my bear are so freaking
excited to build that bed that we're
like let's just start working on that
room first
so hopefully I have enough space because
if not
we're gonna have to take all of that
stuff off and disassemble this bed so
that we have more room but I hope
we like do anything
everyone just saw me turn you on is that
why your nipples are popping up
they're totally not you win I know I do
wish
[Music]
wow look at this handy lady
13. you're about to talk [ __ ] boy nope
look at them look at him she knows what
she's doing you know what she's doing a
lot of [ __ ] dust from Amazon
and I got so far and then to find out
the whole thing was like backwards oh my
God this thing set up where it was like
everything was numbered which I was like
thank you God it's numbered
do you even know what you're doing yeah
putting it in order okay
so just checking
it's like [ __ ] because you know I won't
do anything because you're holding a
camera huh nope
she's a nine or a six
but we'll find out right I mean it's
pretty easy to tell
me that you saw
yourself
so
look at that it's right there
let's look at that right there makes
perfect sense
this is three or three
are you serious
you've seen that 30 like this before
well this one's 30. exactly
so doesn't that answer all of your
questions
I hope you poke your eye out with that
piece of work you're so
weird
just kidding you're so [ __ ] weird so
that is box 105 this is box
two of five are you looking for the
directions yeah but it is also good for
just opening it and cry biologics yeah
don't look down my shirt I'm not
I'm looking at your big back oh thank
you yeah you've been working on those
little lats little baby lats
[Applause]
I like how you clocked big back and you
still took it away from me
yeah they're cute cute little baby Lots
yep 30 or 36.
so this is a lot of individual pieces
this is gonna be a pain in the ass put
together
you sure about that God damn it what the
[ __ ] what happened what is this
33.
what
I believe in this all right
[Music]
38.
shout outs to Universal kids furniture
not a brand deal or anything but they're
from Vegas
just wanted to shout him out and yeah
they're local the guy that delivered it
was so cute like he dropped it off at
our doorstep and he's like hey guys
just want to let you guys know
thank you so much for supporting he
didn't know who you were they're just
like thank you so much for supporting
we're just a brand new company just
trying to start things back up and um
and or just want to start things up and
so it's so cool to like have you guys
order and I was like dude like we were
on the website and you know when we were
trying to get a high sketch I thought it
was sketch why do you think it was
sketch I don't know because there's so
many like companies that show you a
picture of one item and then you buy it
and it's like the super cheap version of
that thing and you're like [ __ ] yeah AKA
Alibaba style yeah yeah I didn't want to
call them out but yeah yeah and um but
when I was looking through the
description like what made me believe in
them was a lot of like kids furniture is
made out of ndf wood or particle wood
which is like not very strong and when
you got a rambunctious kid like taika
who's gonna test the limits of
everything we're like dude if we're
gonna get a bed a bunk bed that has a
slide on it it better be strong you know
so when I looked at it I was like what
solid wood that's dope they barely make
fun to try to solid wood anymore and
usually when they do they're crazy
expensive this was actually still
affordable so I was like let's order and
it was cool that they ended up being
local
yeah this was 9 000. I mean damn baller
[ __ ] hundred nine hundred dollars yes
two beds for one that's pretty good
I can also see why though because you
gotta build literally every single Park
hey I might as well save a thousand
dollars I might as well cut the tree
down myself you know what I'm saying
damn look at those baby Lads going to
work
foreign
so this is what the finished product
looks like you see how CUNY this is and
why me and Margaret love this so much
you got the queen size bed right here
and then you got the twin size bed right
here and you get the little Nook and
then you can slide down oh my God this
is a dream come true look at that
this [ __ ] just
just repeat what you what you said
uh the directions are probably in this
box which is the last spot a tape that
says Hardware sticking out and usually
they keep the hardware with the
instructions why did you wait until all
of this I mean it was eventually gonna
happen I just didn't want it to be in
this order I wanted to start building
foreign
and if you just did it right the first
time you only have to do it once
I am doing it right the first time what
are you talking about I'm making you put
everything in the right order
you [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] well at least I appreciate
them that it came this way because my
desk that I've got from Amazon
that I'm returning now because it was
all [ __ ] up everything was just in a
little bag at least this right here is
like
it's like very organized so I do
appreciate that it's already counted for
me for the Amazon one I had to count
everything by hand because I'm like I'm
not about to build this and then I'm
missing like two of these and then I'm
super [ __ ] so I have to count
everything first what
so the first step that I do because I'm
such a pro handyman no one cares okay
here you go
what wait till like you have all the
answers you're gonna be like oh I need
this special like bolt but I'm gonna use
all the other ones and go through them
first and then go oh yeah I had to use
this one is that what you're gonna do
this is called a screw whatever the [ __ ]
I don't need to know I hired your
dumbass yeah
and I just look for the exact drill bit
that has this and this and we can work
best
here Mom and look who woke up from a nap
you know what this guy started saying he
started saying bruh
hey
it's like a
oh my God it sounds too natural when he
says it really good we sound old when we
said when he says it sounds like breath
but also sounds like oh man this kid's
getting old he's learning all these
slings bruh take an easy breath but I
still like when he says
tiger do you still say cutie pie
oh no oh
my God
so this is why it's super helpful a lot
of Ikea furniture and a lot of like
build at home furniture they actually
use Allen key like this and if you were
to crank all day especially something
with a million pieces like this it's a
pain in the butt so I've built enough
Ikea furniture to know that so when I
started buying
um drill bits I would specifically buy
ones that have like an allen key so now
you can install way faster and I
actually learned this because uh back in
the day when we bought Ikea furniture I
had one of those professional guys build
it and it would take like eight hours to
build one couch remember that one time
where like these three dudes yeah
they're like yeah they built like six
things in two hours and I was like oh
that's the secret so it's important to
have this side
and also don't set it on the max because
I've also done it where it just drills
right through the wood and splits
everything apart so I always test the
like personality of the woods I started
off at like two and then I'll like stop
bad at the point like that and then on
this material I realized like 12 is
pretty good where it doesn't feel like
obliterate it but then when I kept it at
two it was too soft
so you always want to take it easy first
what happened you farted and I hate you
here's the one over there anyways here's
an update looking pretty good
yeah it's interesting because they have
you build the top first so that's the
top bunk where you put the twin size bed
and it lays perpendicular to the queen
size bed I don't know
it is the top it looks like the top
because the twin is up top and there's
just one part I think we kind of messed
up I'm not sure if they messed up but we
have a casualty but most importantly I
just want to make sure that's hike is
safe so all the Locking mechanisms are
super in place
so they're really really tight including
this one right here even though it's
broken on this side but look at that so
hey monkey are you excited about your
bed
CUNY
look at your bed
you like it yeah
we're almost done or what
there's gonna be a slide too yeah you're
gonna slide down
that's fine
Okay so
we didn't quite finish we've been
working on it for how many hours
um maybe if I'm six four hours four
hours okay literally every single screw
that you see we probably put in hundreds
literally hundreds of screws
we're down to the last wire but you know
for taika seizures and stuff we need
them to sleep early so we don't want to
keep working into the night so taika is
sleeping on the top bug which is
freaking comfy and cute look how cute
this is look at it look at this guy even
CUNY does it look comfy mister
and you got little monkeys with them it
feels comfy oh it's sturdy too look at
that like except oh except for this part
we need to work on this I didn't tighten
this oh no yeah I'll tighten that but
then yeah I just gotta knock this part
out
what look look at that there's cracks I
know there's and there's one right here
I put my stuff hey cool yeah grandma
gave that to him and I can reach cutie
pie I can see it in the window it's a
cutie pie
class good night Mister hey